that looks really cool
i love that video i don't know where
she's going but it looks really cool
all right or something
oh into the spider verse by the way
music's choice of this is pretty great i
gotta admit you know yo i love i love
how she just like walks through the air
with the crystals bro i love that look
okay
i'm in the super bowl
in a mirror base
i mean that's all i care about you just
want the big old hand
[Laughter]
she's having so much fun living her best
life in this room i love a superhero
just having fun just being a goof like
that's why i love shows like this
you can't help but love it like i'm
gonna love this show and she's like so
perfect she's a dark she's an adorable
dork and i love adorable exactly i feel
like this
this is a person i was friends with in
high school that like when i was a kid i
had a crush on him like no
i'm just gonna put me alone she's too
cool for me like like
we all had a friend like this in high
school and like that's
like you can imagine her being friends
with peter parker and like i heard i was
appointed the biggest nerd of all time
so like whenever i saw like super nerdy
girls would be like oh my god i get i
mean fear i can't even believe it
i will wait till my senior year of
college to begin uh
[Laughter]
and that was just talking i mean it took
a few years after that for anything
actually to happen but anyway welcome
back to new rock stars miss marvel is
the new mcu superhero in a six episode
series coming to disney plus on june 8th
with iman valani as kamala khan a
pakistani american captain marvel fan
girl living in jersey city who gets her
own powers but since kamala is best
known for her limb stretching and her
fist in biggening why did marvel really
change her powers for this live-action
title
come on come on
i don't know if that works we'll see if
we stick with that anyway this is inside
marvel it's new rockstar's weekly marvel
reaction show and this week we're
talking about kamala khan and how great
iman valani is in this role and the
perhaps deeper reason why marvel might
be updating her power set i'm eric voss
with me is mt bro i am so excited to
finally see kamala khan on the big
screen or on the live action screen
anyway because like it's just i i just
feel like it was yesterday that she that
she just premiered and like now we're
seeing her in live action like this
character means so much to a lot of
people and like especially like
pakistani people so like i'm just
excited i love when like new
representation comes because like i know
that there's going to be a group of
people that are going to be as hype as i
was when black panther came out cause
like it's this is really cool this is
really cool this is like monumental like
i love it it's dope
she's she's so lovable and she's all
personality this one personality
she's just so much fun to watch
um but we want to talk about her power
set i know this is a big question a lot
of people have about the way they're
doing miss marvel um because we're so
accustomed to seeing just like a big old
fist uh but like now people are
wondering well why do they make it look
like a genie projection or a green
lantern kind of thing uh to me i'm just
saying i don't care what color the fist
is as long as we see the fist yeah we
just need the big old fast action
whether it's this fist or uh other
people saying about muffist though uh
that's always gonna be what people are
worried about
it sounds like a disney plus marvelous
mephisto
so we're gonna get to know all about
kamala khan uh this new young hero
joining the avengers lineup and how were
powers work exactly and i actually think
there may be a deeper reason why they
updated it it i don't think it's just to
avoid comparison to mr fantastic uh from
the get-go um and there may be other
things this may just be the early stage
of the evolution of her powers there's
gonna be a lot we talk about there could
be some deeper connection that we're all
missing currently but before we talk
about that keep an eye out in the next
few days for the release of moon night
theme merch from newarkstarsmerch.com
there already is some cool stuff related
to moon night available for purchase on
new yorkstarsmerch.com
uh but they're going to be talking about
a new latest obsession shirt
i can't wait to get it i can't wait for
you guys to see it so sign up for their
newsletter on the website so that that
way you will know exactly when the shirt
is available um but mt what is there a
question coming out of this trailer well
uh come on kamala why is the mcu
changing kamala khan's powers i mean
everyone seems up in arms about it i
mean us i mean we seem to be pretty
chill about it but like why do you think
that happened to her really from the
get-go marvel studios is gonna have to
go in a different direction with kamala
khan's powers and origin story because
uh kamala is a relatively recent
addition as you alluded to mt to the
marvel comics she was introduced only
back in 2013 and at this point the movie
universe was already in its second phase
so uh this is something that like kevin
feige spotted the popularity of and says
oh we gotta we gotta get her in live
action uh so uh kamala was a captain
marvel fan girl who then gets hit with
an outbreak of terrigen mist from like a
terrigen bomb that goes throughout
jersey city and then she enters this as
all inhuman uh evolution happens through
a cocoon and but we actually see a
really cool perspective from her from
inside her cocoon where she envisions
her heroes captain marvel and iron man
and and captain america and they all
speak to her through this cloud of mist
and one cool thing about the kamala khan
comics
is that it's all like lowercase you know
as opposed to like the typical uppercase
uh comic text so it's just like
lowercase it just feels like this is a
teenager scrolling this you know in her
own kind of fan fiction which is part of
the fun of it um
and it's really from her inner desire to
be more like carol danvers captain
marvel that uh that actually results in
her taking on a similar power set except
really what she's known for is this like
goofy but wonderful ability to embig in
her body parts she could stretch her
arms out she can make her fists really
big and she uses that to beat up her
enemies it's just really fun it's really
the best known component of her powers
from the comics but yeah as you may have
seen now in live action uh on we saw
this actually back in the disney plus
day footage in november and now in this
trailer this series is certainly
altering kamala's origin and powers and
it somewhat makes sense because terrigen
mist has been linked with the inhumans
that's the cree technology that they
used to mutate humans into inhumans and
give them powers and we should be
careful i guess using the word mutate
because inhumans and mutants are
different things mutants are born with
the x gene and humans are cree
experiments uh created with that
terrigen mist in the cocoon process uh
we have not really explored terrigen
mist in the mcu films however we did see
it in the tv series of course the
inhumans though the one and done season
that we saw in abc but really an agent's
a shield that's the character quake of
course emerged from the the terrigen
process you don't think there's gonna be
a season two of inhumans eric you don't
think that's coming
i've been waiting for it
i don't know i'm sorry i'm sorry i mean
hey maybe we get black holes on the
illuminati and he whispers something and
everyone's head explodes and then uh and
then he gets to remake the mcu the way
he thinks it should be made but uh
i hope that everything
says is uh we don't talk about season
one pages of uh
we don't talk about inhumans but anyway
uh
yes but quake and agents of shield we
absolutely want to be mcu canon in many
people's mind it is mcu canon never was
an mcu canon even agents of shield final
season gave us a perfect road map of how
this could connect by just being an
alternate timeline and yeah i think the
fact that agents of shield is coming to
disney plus that's that seems to be the
direction they're going and maybe things
like inhumans in quake and terrigen mist
can all just be mcu canon finally
confirmed but uh they are apparently
doing something different with kamala
khan instead her powers come from these
bracelets that she finds in a chest in
an attic now we've speculated these
could be the mega bands from the captain
marvel comics that would link the wearer
to the negative zone or they could be
the quantum bands of quasar that allow
for similar energy projection similar
power sets i think they're just gonna be
something new but with properties from
both of these things um because really
there are two sources of this power that
i think the series might suggest two
sources that could just end up being the
same thing so i'm gonna run through both
options option one being just cree tech
in the negative zone as i mentioned
because since kamala's powers manifest
be a wish fulfillment i think that's the
key and it's very similar to the nature
of the cree supreme intelligence that we
saw you know dr wendy lor lawson uh
annette
was the form that it took but it really
it's a it's an um shape-shifting form
that's whatever is in the mind of the
observer um so the fact that both of
those things are are linked to the fact
that we know that kamala khan's gonna
team up with captain marvel it just
seems like they could be that form of
nega bands that uh transport kamala to
the negative zone and that uh the crease
supreme intelligence draws power from
that and
and all of it is just kind of like your
mind manifests what it is
but
the second option is the quantum realm
because we have long believed that the
quantum realm really was the mcu's
equivalent of the negative zone and that
perhaps the fantastic four actually got
stranded in the quantum realm instead of
the negative zone and got their powers
there along with victor von doom
and that could all link with kang and
quantum mania uh because in ant-man the
wasp janet van dyke told hank pym that
her quantum healing powers were a kind
of evolution from being exposed to
quantum energy for a long period of time
and we also know that quantum realm has
these same kind of mental projection
properties hank pym initially projected
around himself his old home before janet
found him and snapped him out of it so
it has that similar kind of whatever you
want the most in the world is where you
are and what you are uh the quantum
realm has that kind of insanity going on
so we could be seeing a similar thing
with kamala's powers these bracelets
might transport her to the quantum realm
she gets hit with radiation briefly
there and comes back with these new
powers manifested from her own mental
self image just to clarify she does
still embiggen parts of her bodies like
we see her fists get really big a few
times in the trailer and her limbs if
you look closely in a lot of these shots
they are stretching out the difference
is they just kind of have this crystalic
energy layer to them uh that seems to be
projected from her body as opposed to
just like her flesh itself stretching um
and i do think it's still possible for
the source of the kree supreme
intelligence power uh to be from the
quantum realm and that all of this the
negative zone the quantum realm it is
still the same thing and this is
something that might just get revealed
in the marvels or in ant-man the wasp
quantomania and that's really why
they're changing kamala's powers to
better reflect that a clue to that
reveal but mt before we start rolling
you came up with your own thoughts for
why they may be showing it this way what
do you think well first of all like
those are really great thoughts i've
really loved your connection to the
quantum realm on how um hank pym like
really just ended up projecting using
his mind to like project things here
because like that's sort of um the
similar vibe that we're seeing here with
with kamala khan here so i really like
that connection because like she sort of
uses her like this her whatever power
that she has for this bracelet to like
sort of project this like purple thing
like purple essence out of her sort of
like hank pym did so i like that
connection there i was mentioning
earlier that like this could very well
be like the early stages potentially of
um kamala khan
actually becoming the
kamala khan that we know from the comics
like the stretchy um woman the stretchy
little girl because um in the series we
know that kamala khan really loves
captain marvel and captain marvel's
powers are very energy based and like
she likes to project energy from her
hands and so we see kamala do this in
the trailer when she uses energy blast
to close the door on her dad so um i
think that throughout this series and we
hear it in the trailer of her mom just
being like who are you like like who are
you like you want to be captain marvel
so badly but who are you as a person
kamala and so i think that there is a
potential for this series to sort of be
an origin story where like this these
bracelets sort of like
help you enhance who you are so like
whereas when she stops wanting to be
captain marvel wants to be herself maybe
like we see a different form of her
powers manifesting through this stretchy
ability who knows that's just a theory i
like that theory i like that i think
there's there's plenty of room in this
mcu for multiple characters who can
stretch out turn themselves into sails
or or
big old fists like the fact that we
already have like i don't know three to
four different characters who are
essentially iron man right you have you
have iron man you have war machine who's
basically doing the same thing and uh
the iron spider armor is essentially a
variant of iron man armor you have
pepper pot's rescue armor which is
basically another iron man in the in the
game like and then we have like captain
america is just like the best of the
super soldiers which is the same power
set as bucky barnes which is the same
power set as a john walker so like if we
can have like multiple versions of those
things why can't we have multiple
stretchers like you know there's nothing
wrong with that true hopefully i think
let's get elastigirl into the mcu
i think that's what we need to just uh
we gotta elastigirl into multiverse and
madness okay let's get that you're
trying to get elastigirl into every
conversation
i'm a big elastic girl
um she's uh she's a good mom we all are
we are yeah we're
every every gentleman of a certain age
is a fan
that's when i knew i liked women eric
that's when i knew
you got it you got to drag me off pixar
pier when i go to california
no she might come back
she's coming no yeah i think
[Laughter]
i think uh i i think
all characters when they get introduced
into the mcu their powers evolve over
time like even iron man's abilities
movie to movie have gotten more uh
expanded more enhanced a scarlet witch
entered age of ultron is just doing her
hand dancing and now she can project
reality in crazy ways and become an
insane sorcerer so give it time give it
time i from what i've seen so far this
is totally fun and what i like most
about this character is just what iman
villani is bringing to the role and how
how she's just like a goofy teenager
dealing with bullies and uh dealing with
like family issues and and her uh
cultural norms coming into conflict with
what she wants like i'm far more
interested in that you know like yeah i
love this really just it seems really
realistic and it seems like you're just
really just grounded just like hey
i'm just a goofy kid like i'm not like
you know
like
like i feel like a lot of superhero
comics especially like when the comic
books first started there was always
like this ingrained sense of like i can
do it like immediately and like
obviously like she feels like she can do
it through like um you know captain
marvel's inspiration here but like it
just you could just sort of see like how
like
how is this girl going to become a
superhero like how is like i feel like
we're it's going to be a lot more
relatable because we're going to see her
mess up we're going to see her just sort
of fumble her way into becoming a hero
that she's always wanted to be like i
like that perspective rather than you
know i'm tony stark and i already have
the means and the confidence and like i
can already sort of kick ass already um
by myself and like the way she stumbles
into this is something that's natural
for her character it's not an accident
it looks like she's like her mom might
confiscate her cosplay outfit so she
goes to the attic looking for other
stuff to put on finds these bracelets
saying this kind of looks like cree
stuff from what i've seen puts it on and
it's actual cree tech and then when she
goes to this a day convention where
she's cosplaying it accidentally
activates so it's through her actual
want to emulate this uh she's a
cosplayer and that it's like the wish
fulfillment of everyone who's cosplayed
at comic con or any of these conventions
what if like what if this blinking iron
man arc reactor actually worked and i
could actually fly in this moment like
that what an exciting thing that any fan
ever who is dressed up as these
characters for a convention for a fan
event for for halloween or just any day
of the weekend alone in our bedrooms
like we could relate to this you know
what if this actually worked like how
exciting i would be geeking out just
like her man i would be her probably the
exact same reactions i'd be like all
right time to if i mean for me i love
frogman so if i got a frog based power
they'd like time to pretend to be
frogman and get myself immediately
killed um so yes um i i feel this i'm a
doctor i think that's what's most
exciting about the series i think
everyone can truly relate with that also
relating with like a high school um uh
uh career counselor
saying can you plan out your entire life
um you know pick a college because this
college has the best major and then uh
you'll have to take this class this
house that's in this class oh and you
should have already been doing this
middle school because you know if you
haven't already tested this oh you're
screwed you're screwed you're screwed
like that that pressure of feeling like
you have to have your entire life
figured out when you're 16 or 17 years
old like i have a sister that is going
through this exact same thing with
college and like yeah no i could totally
yeah it's the worst and like i remember
going through it myself and like there's
a lot of just pressure at that specific
time so to become a superhero during
that time not really great for your
grades i'm assuming yeah especially and
um
i don't want to derail any like uh if
you're a younger person watching this
video right now i know most of our the
people who watch us or might be a little
bit older but
uh
you don't have to have it all figured
out you totally do not have to figure it
out and anyone who tells you that is
just trying they're just also trying to
figure it out in their 40s and 50s or
however old they are because they are
following these guidelines freaking out
that they're going to lose their job if
they don't help kids get into college
better colleges because they're dealing
with all their pressures too but even if
like you don't get to the right college
it's not going to be the wrong college
you're going to you're going to figure
it out you're going to meet people there
uh or even if you don't go to college if
you take a gap year or you don't want to
go to college you're going to figure out
where you need to go and it's going to
be great it's going to be awesome so
don't worry just don't worry all you
have to get to where you need to go
like honestly like
all life is just living a life according
to your values so as long as you know
what your values are at the moment and
then you just just trust yourself you'll
figure it out like trust me no one
really knows what they're doing that's
the secret to life no one knows what
they're doing even all the adults that
they tell you that they know what
they're doing they're lying because like
we're all we're literally on a globe
floating in space where no one knows
what they're doing so
hooray just do what you want you can do
it and yep and i'll tell you i never
thought youtube er would be a job but it
exists now and
if you think being an influencer is a
job you want trust me there's gonna be
new technologies new industries that
exist by the time you're entering the
workforce and you'll figure it out
you're gonna you're gonna take my job
and then like destroying your rock stars
with something better so uh
come at us take our time seriously like
the next new rock stars our replacements
uh when we're old uh they're gonna come
this could be you so uh this has
accidentally become therapy for teens
none of whom are probably watching this
video anyway but if you are after school
special save this for me from your uncle
mt and uncle eric we got your backs
we're here for you we're keeping the
seat warm for you uh
[Laughter]
we are terrible influences probably
anyway um
we're gonna get back to this
conversation of uh who kamala khan might
be fighting in this show who's gonna be
the villain the antagonist the foe of
this show um and why she will eventually
join the marvels in uh the marvels
coming next year but first we want to
thank some people who helped us make
this episode our vincent helix mt and i
have to be on our a game during inside
marvel recording sessions we can't
afford to have a bad night of sleep
because of a crappy mattress that's why
we love our helix mattresses thanks to
helix for sponsoring this episode helix
sleep is a quiz that matches your body
type and your sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you they have soft
medium and firm mattresses matches is
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot even uh even a helix plus mattress
for plus size sleepers i have a helix
mattress and i love it mt's helix
mattress is getting delivered soon so
he'll report back
in some future episodes you got it
already we've got those talking points
how did your thoughts empty how do you
feel bro like my god i've been sleeping
on this for a week and this is not even
like a calf this is not even
exaggeration my sleep has literally
improved so much from my old mattress
like i
my life like my whole body feels so much
better so i feel so refreshed so please
look at the helix my god i i you heard
the man folks
from god's mouth to your ears
he loves his mattress and you will love
it too we're not just shills reading
copy we both sleep on helix mattresses
it really has been the best sleep of our
lives
get yourself a helix it ships right to
your door for free no need to go to a
mattress store just go to helixsleep.com
inside marvel take their two minute
sleep quiz they'll match into a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10 year warranty and you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you will helix is offering
up to 200 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners at
helix sleep.com inside marvel we also
want to thank upstart for sponsoring
this episode if you have multiple credit
card balances each month and are only
paying the minimums barely making a dent
in your credit card debt it can be
discouraging but upstart can help you
pay off your existing debt quickly so
you can feel like you're finally getting
ahead whether it's paying off your
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt or funding personal expenses over a
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date upstart knows you are more
than just your credit score so rather
than looking at your credit score alone
upstart's model considers other factors
like your income your employment other
information provided in your loan
application to find you a smarter rate
for your loan you can check your rate
without impacting your credit score in
just five minutes for loads between one
thousand and fifty thousand dollars you
can receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com marvel that's upstart.com
marvel don't forget to use our url to
let them know that we sent you loan
amounts to be determined based on your
credit income and certain other
information providing your loan
application go to upstart.com marvel we
also want to thank stance for sponsoring
this episode we're big fans of the socks
from stance here at new rockstars
they're super comfortable and have great
designs they also have some very cool
designs that i love like uh ones made in
collaboration with pixar the nba star
wars now they're expanding with all new
active apparel line they have a super
soft line of sweatpants and joggers
shirts hoodies hats and more embrace the
life of superior comfort and creative
expression with everyday active apparel
that truly is stitched different it's
always fun when you sit down and your
socks show just a little bit under your
pants to reveal a cool design show
yourself off
now both the pants and the socks can be
from stance stance's philosophy is that
you should never have to sacrifice your
own personal style for the sake of
comfort and now you don't have to
whether you're relaxing around the house
working out at the gym or running all
over town stance now delivers its
signature softness and creativity and a
full line of active apparel styles from
toe to head stance has got you covered
head on over to stance.com and get 15
off your first purchase use the promo
code marvel at checkout to apply enjoy
the color and comfort of a life less
ordinary with stance stitched different
all right empty back to this miss marvel
trailer i want to ask you who do you
think will be the villain of this miss
marvel series or will it have a villain
see that's so that's the big question
because this trailer didn't really show
us give us a really good idea of who the
villain will be when we see these four
figures standing where it appears to be
like an alley of some sort um and like
they're just it gets covered by smoke
and we don't really get a good look at
their faces um i think a previous
trailer sort of like had their faces
sort of glitching out a little bit like
a weird purple glitch out um i could be
maybe i was bugging with that maybe it's
a weird flame uh framing thing um but no
i i think that we could potentially be
looking at some type of you know
extraterrestrial
um cree related threat here that's what
i was gonna say i think this is an
opportunity to introduce the koreas of
villains yeah and like i i honestly feel
like the bigger question here is like
why was that bracelet
in kamala's what appears to be kamala's
attic and like i think that kamala's mom
has more
to her than meets the eye i think she
could possibly be a scroll here and i
think that that's what's going to say we
don't know if it's her mom or just
someone else she's like looking after or
snooping around their place but i think
you're right i think that's that's
someone is a scroll yeah i think that
someone in her lineage is a squirrel or
related and maybe her father's a creep
that would be crazy if her father was a
cree and she was this girl
and like they were just adapted to um
our cultures here on earth but like um
no like i think that whatever is
happening here there is that connection
to the cosmic like she says in the
trailer and um i think i don't know i
just like it's either gonna be a cree
type villain like your uh your yawn
rocks from captain marvel or um or a
cree adjacent villain cause like in the
comics she she faces um this villain
named cameron who's in the movie as um
this really attractive um
love interest that she has in in the
trailer and in in her um in the comics
series as well and uh he ends up being a
villain by the name of why am i blanking
on his name i think his name is just
cameron uh but he has a he's a he has
he's a new human like she is in the
comics and uh he works for this villain
by the name of lineage who is his big
purple demon man and um i think that we
could be a c a secret lineage cameo
because of that weird purple flicker
that i saw or i thought i saw um in an
earlier trailer um on those four people
but uh i don't know who knows at this
point i think it could just be a um a
crew related person but who do you think
yeah i don't think i need her parents to
be crees or squirrels um i think
like we've seen too much of like
the the parent is also going through the
thing this is like a lineage or a
bloodline thing i kind of like her
parents just being
uh her parents and and representing
that part of her life to her but i think
someone in her life maybe her her aunt
or
her grandmother or some or someone
unrelated to her preferably uh that she
has to like look after someone in her
community i think it'd be really cool a
cool opportunity to have that person be
a scroll and then that's the squirrels
were keeping this cree weapon away from
their cree uh enemies i i think i don't
know if this show um might feel too
overwhelmed to be in the midst of a cree
squirrel shadow war but just hinting at
that war existing while uh kamala khan
is stuck in the middle of it could be a
really really fascinating backstory that
gets revisited in secret invasion it
sets up that that bigger conflict to
come to a boiling point in secret
invasion uh because other than squirrels
just existing in the mcu um and other
than that one little line of fury slash
taylor saying i thought cree having
sleep or so is supposed to be top secret
information um we haven't really gotten
any indication
that this war is going on also the fact
that squirrel were introduced in captain
marvel as uh at least taylor's group
being
a pretty good group of folks
uh like marvel needs to do a bit more
explaining who are the true villains of
the secret invasion conflict tonight i
think we need to learn more who the cree
are and how villainous they they really
are in the marvel world
uh so this could be a good place to do
it oh yeah for sure this this show is
definitely the place that it's going to
definitely go into the more cosmic side
because we see that um kamala khan is so
obsessed with space you look all over a
room there's stars there's planets and
there's rocket ships and like there's
she goes to that little captain marvel
thing and there's like planets all
around i feel like that's the space is
going to be a huge part of this and
um
the villain could very well be tied to
the cree for sure because then we have
to like we're going to talk about next
we have to see that connection to the
marvels and the marvels are
inherently connected to the tesseract
and the cree and all that stuff so yeah
so and let's shift over to that final
question why and how will kamala join
captain marvel and monica rambo in that
movie the marvels the marvels of all the
announced titles is probably the one
that
i have the most trouble depicting what
that story will be i understand that the
characters i just don't understand
what that conflict will be
where it will take place is it going to
be on earth is it going to be on holla
is it going to be like in earth's orbit
is it going to be on the eternals based
on the moon uh where captain america is
we all think right now um
like uh how is kamala gonna get uh
sucked into that conflict i honor i
honestly think that it's gonna be
through the scrolls and it's gonna be
through that connection that the scrolls
have to this
technology that kabbalah has come across
because we as we see in captain marvel a
lot of the squirrels technology operates
on this weird purple
um technology this purple energy and
that's the same type of energy with the
same color at rather that kamala exudes
from her from her bracelet and we know
from the at the end of blonde division
that you know monica gets whisked up
into space by a skrull and then captain
marvel has a relationship with the
skrulls so i think that the skrulls are
what are going to be the uniting force
for captain marvel monica rambo and
miss marvel here um then that's going to
be the main thing that draws them
together so i think that it's going to
be a sprawl type conflict there yeah i
think what we might see in star wars is
that cree get introduced as kind of like
the galactic empire of star wars like
just this new intergalactic threat that
goes planet by planet invading it taking
it over setting up this kind of fascist
regime uh and i think that's the that's
the kind of plot i want to see explored
on the galactic fronts like yeah on one
side we have gore the god butcher
killing everyone who's got associated in
uh thor love and thunder uh whatever and
then we have whatever is going to be the
plot of guardians of the galaxy vol 3.
but i i think we need a new galactic
villain and i i think decree need to be
established as that so if you imagine
like captain marvel fighting the good
fight alongside monica rambo and uh
in kamala khan as kind of the rebels of
that of that story i think that could be
a really cool opportunity to explore
some kind of like space civil war stuff
planets exploding uh not just from uh
celestials hatching out of them oh yeah
i definitely feel like we're they're
setting up some type of intergalactic
situation between like the korea and the
squirrels and like other races in the
galaxy that are going to yeah have some
gpr or somewhere
for sure like they're coming it's going
to be freaking dope but i cannot wait
[Laughter]
but no um i definitely feel like they're
setting up this this this huge conflict
between all these races but then i feel
like they're gonna have them all come
together to face a greater conflict uh
like the builders like they did in um
the infinity saga um where all the right
all these alien races have to come
together to fight a bigger threat um
making like this huge intergalactic
avengers force that is basically like
the star wars and i really want that to
happen i know kevin feige is a big fan
of star wars so let's let's make that
happen like at mcu star wars for me i
want all these different civilizations
to be constantly at war with each other
i never wanted to be resolved i always
want there to be room for conflict i
want some star wars forever you always
want like your ronin uh sub group to
split off and screw everything up
you always want like some scrolls to be
like peaceful refugees and some just to
be like terrorist [ __ ] like i want
their i want to be like constant
conflict on the galactic fronts
exactly just because i want them to
always hate each other i think that's
more fun um but anyway we'll leave it
there for this episode of inside marvel
this was a delight to rip open this
trailer for all the implications that it
now opens up in the mcu as always it is
a delight empty um now don't forget to
check out our many great merch options
in newarkstoresmerch.com again moon
night merch is coming you can follow me
at eavos follow mt at mastertainment
subscribe to inside marvel wherever you
get your podcasts thank you all for
watching bye
you